The question we want to think about is
how you could define who your ancestors are. The
way to think about ancestors. Well, here's you.
Hopefully, you're smiling, because you're enjoying learning about recursive
definitions. And you had some parents. Let's assume
you had two. And we won't assume whether of
not your parents are smiling, but let's hope
at least one of them is. And your parents
were your ancestors, but they're not all
of your ancestors. Your parents had parents, as
well. These are your grandparents. Grandparents are always
happy. So, they're all smiling. And your grandparents,
well, they also had parents. Those would
be your great-grandparents, and so forth. And all
of these, except yourself, are your ancestors. So
our goal now is to define that precisely.
Can we come up with a definition that describes
exactly this same relationship, all the ancestors that you
have? So the question is, which of these is
the best definition of ancestors? And there are three
choices, the first has one rule, ancestor is replaced
by parent of ancestor. The second has two rules,
ancestor is replaced by parent, and ancestor is replaced
by parent of the ancestor. The third has three rules.
Ancestor is replaced by parent. Ancestor is replaced by parent
of parent. And ancestor's replaced by parent of parent of ancestor.